هذه إيلين
جولاندا تروجيلو وهذا ألفريدو أنطونيو
تروجيلو في مركز ناتيفيداد الطبي. مجموعة من
التوائم الأخوية ولد واحد وفتاة واحدة
في أيام مختلفة في
شهر مختلف وسنة مختلفة ولدت في 11
وولدت في 12 منتصف الليل طفل
إيلين تدخل العالم بوزن 5 أرطال
و 14 أونصة وطفل ألفريدو يزن
ستة أرطال وأوقية واحدة
كل عام ، هناك حوالي مائة
وعشرون ألف حالة ولادة توأم في
البلاد أي ما يزيد قليلاً عن ثلاثة بالمائة
من جميع الولادات ، ومع ذلك فإن التوائم ذات
أعياد الميلاد المختلفة نادرة للغاية.
تقدير فرصة أن يكون
تاريخ الاستحقاق الأصلي لمونتريال واحدًا من بين مليونين هو السادس عشر من كانون الثاني (يناير)
حتى حصلت على مفاجأة غير متوقعة.
حتى الآن
في المهد ، أشعر بالسعادة الشديدة لأنني أنجب
طفلين ،
إنها تجربة جديدة ،
لكنهم جعلوني سعيدًا
جدًا ويقولون إنها كانت سعيدة للغاية  وسعداء فقط
لدخولهم العالم بصحة جيدة
وهي لحظة تعتز بها كل أم ،
أنا ممتن حقًا
للأطباء والممرضات الذين ساعدوني
في متابعة عملية الحصول عليهم
ووصولهم
بصحة جيدة